la visite commencera ici à la clé des
champs cette salle de spectacle de 300
places s'adresse principalement aux 16
30 ans à la base c'est une salle de
musique actuelle dédiée pour des
concerts mais il y a aussi des studios
de répétition qu'on peut voir derrière
nous ou en statistique en moyenne vous
avez C groupes par semaine qui viennent
répéter ici de façon assez régulière
concert tremplin des voix ou jam session
avec le Conservatoire la clé des champs
propose 10 sac 15 soirées chaque saison
à de pas de là le tech le théâtre espace
Coluche avec plus de 25 représentations
la salle accueille chaque saison près de
30000 spectateurs ici le public
découvrira principalement la sensation
d'être sur scène une des anecdotes qui
fait toujours rire pourquoi pas de verre
au théâtre pourquoi pas le mot je le
dirais même pas ici
CDE voilà toutes ces petites choses
qu'on apprend qui sont les un peu la
tradition c'est vrai que c'est un peu
moins respecté mais ça reste la
tradition j'aurais le moyen de montrer
au public d'éteindre la salle d'allumer
le plateau ce qu'on appelle en plein feu
pour qu'il se rend compte que quand on a
tous ces projecteurs dans la figure ben
on ne voit plus le public on ne fait que
le ressentir côté court côté jardin ou
travail en régie après ces journées du
patrimoine les salles plaisiroises
n'auront plus de
secret